e o atores vou tentar deixe ficar aqui
neste neste ciclo Essa é a parte mais
difícil se sair faço assim tá bem ou não
é ruim mãe hoje estou aqui a jogar em
casa uma vez que eu sou professor aqui
no colégio em carnaxide e eventos com
disso o Patrick vai me falar sobre um
funk com professor que sou venho falar
sobre o Infante numa sala mas numa sala
numa sala de aula digamos assim vamos lá
disso nós nos últimos tempos eu quando
quando comecei a pensar o que é que ia
falar pensei em falar sobre estes
últimos tempos que temos vivido sobre a
pandemia e calculei que queria um tema
que em algum ponto de partida até porque
durante estes últimos tempos fomos
desafiados a sair da nossa zona de
conforto fomos desafiados a sair do
nosso espaço até onde habitualmente
trabalha a trabalhar vamos aê Batista
que afetou muito sofrimento
a ansiedade muitos desafios e creio que
tudo isto se resume ao conceito filhos
em casa não é e não não ficou tudo bem
como sabemos na realidade todos durante
este último ano e qualquer coisa fomos
desafiados a sair bastante da nossa zona
de conforto principalmente os pais
porque perceberam que era a vida de um
professor a e os professores perceberem
que preferiam 25 ou 30 alunos na sala de
aula do terem os filhos em cima online A
por isso é que apareceu aqui também esta
esta este elefante elefante que ver é o
Ricardo Ricardo trezzi
eu não vou fazer mais isto a última vez
o Ricardo esta voz e o Ricardo era a
figura principal dos vídeos que a minha
mulher que é Educadora também no colégio
no trabalho fazia para os seus alunos de
3 e 4 anos e de repente o Ricardo fui eu
durante um ano ao durante uns meses a
fui eu Ricardo que tinha de fazer vídeos
e isso também foi para mim um grande
desafio porque eu não estava habituado a
ser um elefante pus a verdade é que foi
compensador e todos estes desafios
acabam por trazer Recompensas
principalmente porque eu via quando
regressarmos ao melhor quando a minha
mulher regressou à escola eu começo do
pré-escolar só gostou primeiro eu fiquei
em casa e de vez em quando tinha que
fazer chamadas para a minha mulher em
alta voz a colocar o Ricardo a falar com
os pequeninos e as duas lá dizem todos
contentes e o Ricardo é o Ricardo mesmo
depois quando eu regressei à escola uma
menina que me disse fui eu sei que tu és
irritar a por isso
e desafiados a sair da nossa zona de
conforto a todos nós professores hoje
vamos ter aqui uma youtuber assim é
conhecida mas todos nós durante alguns
professores forem YouTubers durante este
por esta durante este confinamento e o
anterior de repente eu posso Este é o
canal da minha mulher e se quiserem se
inscrever não sou brincar o durante
estes meses o que aconteceu foi a minha
mulher precisava de ajuda para enviar um
e-mail ao ano e qualquer coisa agora tem
um canal no YouTube edita os vídeos e
tudo mais isso de fato mostra o pão
resilientes nós fomos e o a capacidade
de mudar as nossas as nossas práticas e
de fato sair da nossa zona de conforto
é só que o como penso nestas coisas e
todos nós devemos pensar será que mudou
assim tanto nos últimos meses nós
assistimos a uma mudança de facto nas
abordagens dos professores Será Que Será
que houve de fato essa mudança a lógica
do mestre-escola que está uma hora a
falar os 50 minutos a falar para os
alunos e depois faz uma ficha é muito
diferente de uma aula de time só de
sumir durante 50 minutos se falarmos e
depois enviamos um forno se para os
alunos preencherem não será isto apenas
um nesta escola a distância o
mestre-escola 2.0 utilizar estes termos
e eu creio que é precisamente aí que nós
devemos pensar nós o mundo mudou e nós
temos de mudar mas também mudaram os
nossos alunos as nossas crianças mudaram
na forma como participam no seu nas suas
vivências do dia a dia as crianças hoje
tem uma participação nas decisões da
família que alguns anos não tínhamos
quem ver mais
o panda do que outro canal qualquer
coloca o dedo lá não deixa dar Max não é
preciso até poucos alguns dias também
ver o canal Panda eles vêm o YouTube
YouTube trouxemos os computadores em vez
de estarem variados que estão bugados
sabem esse tempo em vez de pequeninos
verem até para a porquinha ver a Peppa
Pig e toda esta mudança é uma mudança
que de fato Depois tem um impacto grande
nas vidas dos nossos alunos só que há
coisas que não mudaram por exemplo nós
quando quando trabalhamos o
desenvolvimento da criança ouvimos falar
muitas vezes das funções executivas as
funções executivas tem a ver com
habilidades que se vão desenvolvendo a
partir a partir de que nascemos mas
depois mais nos quatro cinco seis anos e
Essas funções esportivas permitem que
nós temos adulto funcionais e que nós
podemos podemos olhar isso como se fosse
em etapas EA primeira etapa Passa muito
pelo autocontrole o autocontrole a
criança tem que se autocontrolar
eu tenho de ter uma autorregulação para
conseguir uma fase posterior utilizar a
sua memória de trabalho nós nos
queixamos muito que não somos capazes de
memorizar que temos o Benfica a
dificuldade em memorizar Esse é um facto
mas também há o processo de
auto-regulação que pois permite a ver
uma capacidade de assimilarmos a
informação e fazemos até que estamos em
relações esse remete-nos para a última
função executiva que é funcionar a
flexibilidade cognitiva que permite que
primeiro de primeira alto regulamos e
depois fomos capazes de utilizar a
memória do trabalho e por fim
estabelecer relações entre aquilo que
aprendemos e a podemos usar a nossa
criatividade porque nós ouvimos falar da
criatividade como ao que vai nascer
assim espontaneamente as pessoas que
nascem com a criatividade temos aqui uma
pessoa muito especialista em
criatividade ao invés de vocês vão à
Vila mas a verdade é que eu tenho aqui
atividade também se trabalho e quando
falo da querer
a contar a história do Bruno e o Bruno
era um daqueles foi o meu primeiro grupo
já em 2001 ele não estava muito desenhar
e ela dá cansamos que se trabalhava
despachar muito depressa E era uma nunca
muitas competências e muito criativo eu
logo na primeira semana e os alunos
fazem as coisas muito parece no primeiro
ano nós normalmente encher chouriços com
desenhos agora faz um desenho e eu pedi
a ele para fazer um desenho passar dois
minutos apareceu o desenho e o desenho
tinha um menino e uma árvore eu disse
algo Está giro mas os meninos desenham
sem parar uma algumas nuvens o sol ele
muito rápido rapidamente isso não está
nevoeiro e passada e eles pois desenha
mais qualquer coisinha passar duas
semanas eu pedi outra vez para fazer um
exame Mas neste caso o desenho Era mesmo
sobre a sua rua e eu faço um desenho
assim dois minutos e quando estou
desenho tinha um prédio as nuvens e o
sol já já
E aí só eu disse pobre então então e
esta estrada não tem carro não tem nada
ele não esta Estrada Está cortada ao
trânsito e de fácil tinha muita
criatividade em dar respostas um entanto
quando nós queremos desenvolver a
criatividade a criatividade assim do
perverso por faca a pessoas que são
muito criativas a outras pessoas que são
menos criativas mas nós promover a
criatividade Passa muito por incentivar
os alunos a criarem sem criar uns não
incentivamos a criatividade hoje aquela
ditadura da criatividade quase e da
colaboração são competências muito
importantes mas há pessoas que tem mais
do que o desenho evitavam só uma boa
forma de trabalhar os a criatividade é
precisamente com trabalho de projeto
projetos toda a gente fala de projeto
trabalho muito em projet projeto está
sempre presente no dia a dia mas depois
eu faço gosto de fazer a pergunta se
fato pessoas trabalham em projeto ou se
fazem trabalhos do grupo algumas coisas
um bocado diferentes um trabalho projeto
Tem que haver um com
Esse é o primeiro Pilar todos que muitas
vezes detratores do trabalho de projecto
gostam de dizer que a gente agora não é
preciso saber nada tudo em projeto não
não há projetos em conhecimento e esse é
o Pilar Face não tá aparecer ali mas o
primeiro Pilares digitar Branco primeiro
Pilar é o conhecimento mas não faz mal
hálito que ensina sobre o Pilar ao
conhecimento sem conhecimento não há
projeto depois o segundo Pilar até posso
fazer um segundo e o terceiro é o Rigor
EA disciplina sem seguidores sem
disciplina um projeto nunca chegará a um
ponto é possível espera aborto e depois
os profetas da exigência gosta muito de
dizer que a exigência são testes e
sensação exames exercícios os rankings
agora estão na ordem do dia mas a
exigência quando se trabalha em projeto
tem que ser muito exigente senão o
projeto não vai avançar e não vai
acontecer aquilo que todos queremos um
projeto que é que haja conhecimento a o
trabalho projeto está em sempre agora
vou passar para o próximo celular que eu
ligo corro muito bem à
e o próximo slide atenta crítica atenta
que mostrar como é que normalmente nós
vemos o projeto normalmente
procrastinamos durante os tempos andamos
adiar o começar a trabalhar hoje quando
faltam dois ou três dias a conhecemos a
fazer listas de tarefas a começamos a
entrar em Pânico e depois acaba o
projeto quando acaba o projeto nós vamos
fechar que não tivemos tempo suficiente
para fazer o projeto e depois dizem que
isso não se volto a repetir mas repente
O que nós vamos fazer quando trabalhamos
com os alunos é precisamente desenvolver
a questão da gestão do projeto em que um
produto final não é o mais importante
quando se fala de aprendizagem mas sim o
processo de aprendizagem é que é
importante ou seja o que o aluno aprende
durante o processo é que vai permitir
que o aluno desenvolva e adquirir as
competências que todos nós queremos o
primeiro projeto nós fizemos nesta
lógica no colégio que fizemos nesta
lógica de gestão de projeto com um
grande Store mapa mental larva de
atividades a
a ação do projeto e depois as lições
aprendidas frango gente era o projeto
sobre o Magro os projetos começam com
uma pergunta de partida e aqui a
pergunta de partida é conhece somar e
depois vamos tiveram desenvolver um
Brainstorm a partir disso a e o Breno
forma muito importante principalmente se
for escrito como se vê ali naquele eu
peço desculpa pela fotografia mas ele é
uma servir mesmo do depósito que era tão
que eu tirei com um gral grande e depois
tive que aumentar isso aqui tudo assim
pixelizado mas aquela menina que dorme
aumentar das mais peladinhas e das
alunas que tinha muito receio participar
escreveu que queria fazer um bar e
discoteca para trabalhar um tema do mar
na altura todos rimos e tal e ou blocos
chacota de parte dos colegas para
discoteca e nestas coisas do trabalho de
projeto normalmente são as ideias mais
loucas e quem trabalha em projeto sabe
que as ideias mais loucas é que acabam
por avançar às vezes não é só pela ideia
louca porque tem projeto nós juntamos as
ideias umas às outras EA partir umas das
outras vamos criar uma
E aí a gente pegamos nessa ideia de
neste caso Party discoteca e a verdade é
que realizamos de fato vai discoteca via
cartazes sobre o mar havia as comidas os
portugueses gostam sempre da parte da
comida não é a comida tinham nomes de
animais e de plantas da biodiversidade
Marinha e depois tínhamos até um jogo um
espaço no vários peteca que tinha um
jogo onde os homens podiam mostrar os
conhecimentos sobre o Magos e facto os
alunos aprenderão muito sobre o Magno ao
mesmo tempo o projeto foi deles e
caminhando para a parte de seguinte o
que acontece é que nós quando fazemos
parte a este tipo de trabalho projeto a
diferentes aprendizagens que são feitas
a qualquer princípio ou em princípio de
cada projeto está sempre o conceito de
interdisciplinaridade eu dou sempre
exemplo isto foi um projeto que partir
da ideia do começo do mundo e os homens
quiseram fazer as experiências na altura
estavam segundo ano e eu vi uma
jornalista que pediu para ir
o colégio para saber como é que você
trabalhava em um projeto eu disse olha
nós temos a fazer um projeto de ciências
por isso será interessante ver como é
que eles trabalham em projetos Então ela
entrou na sala e viu Este grupo naquela
estrutura que pregaram pintar os cabelo
pintado altura iam pendurar umas umas os
Cordeiros e os fios com as garrafas de
vidro e depois encher com diferentes
quantidades de água e andando e um tocar
o hino do colégio ali naquela
instrumento musical e ela a jornalista
chegou ao pé daquela atalides passado
por isso eu tinha dito que era um
projeto de ciências mas vocês estão aqui
mostrar muita coisa e a Clara disse
assim muito admirada claro então quando
trabalhamos em projeto não trabalhamos
só uma disciplina e essa é o mais
importante do trabalho projeto eu quando
faço um projeto não sou a fazer um
projeto de matemática de ciências onde
inglês o que é que seja os conteúdos são
todos trabalhados ao mesmo tempo porque
assim na vida
e eu por isso é que é importante nos
arriscarmos Nós deixamos os alunos
pegarem em pistolas de cola quente mesmo
de vez em quando possa queimar um
dedinhos e também não há mal nenhum é
isso é importante nós somos capazes de
cruzar diferentes competências nos
alunos e eles também saírem da sua
própria zona de conforto hoje em dia
falamos muito deste facto Eu gostei
muito não gosto sempre de ouvir o Marco
falar sobre a importância das ciências
da tecnologia da engenharia da
matemática mas cada vez mais se fala
destinee amanhã uma palavra em inglês e
este me acrescentam ali a criatividade
como estás trazem as artes e por isso as
artes são indispensáveis para nós
desenvolvemos o conjunto das outras
competências deste tempo aquele tempo
Estava a ler um artigo que dizia que
atualmente é importante nós
acrescentamos a língua a leitura o íris
até numa altura em que a planta notícia
circular Muitas delas não são não são
propriamente dignas é cada vez mais
importante nós desenvolvemos esta
capacidade de ler e de
nós colhemos príncipe Alexandre Kalil R
fica Extreme riding a e ele por
iniciativa própria aqui há uns tempos
adicionei ali o USB Benfica streaming
por causa da importância do desporto e
da actividade física e dos cultivarmos
também esta distância de terão o corpo
saudável o que remonta muito ao passado
não é ao conceito de mente sã em corpo
são esta a dar uma volta não é e de
facto as Termas são muito importantes
mas todas as áreas são também elas muito
importantes eu gosto particularmente de
falar sobre o tamanho não só sobre esta
tão das áreas serem todas importantes
mas também os talentos das pessoas nós
temos a principal figura em Portugal em
Portugal Portuguesa no mundo é um tipo
tem uma qualidade extraordinária para
dar uns pontapés na bola e nós
continuamos a dizer que as competências
essenciais ou as competências as
disciplinas nucleares são a matemática
ou português tem a sua importância
assunto
em reais o entanto nós temos que
respeitar a escola tem que respeitar os
talentos das Crianças a diversidade das
preço das peças e dos professores também
e creio que é esse sim o o elefante nós
temos na sala não é o Ricardo Coitadinho
é este elefante que nós todos temos que
ponto de começar a pensar que é
necessário trazer trazer mais para as
nossas escolas o elefante é a mudança é
a necessidade de nós abraçarmos a outras
práticas de nós somos capazes de pensar
que os alunos não são todos iguais e que
devemos mudar não e deixe-os aqui
precisamente a frase de que o o a
mudança é essencial não porque todos
queremos mudar mas principalmente por
mudaram ao uma loucura e não é uma
Utopia é uma Justiça Mas é uma justiça
para a sociedade e principalmente na
justiça para os nossos alunos obrigado
E aí